when you own a stock you're owning a
fractional share of a company
now there's three things that i always
like to keep people wary of when they
buy a stock the first is is there's
sometimes a perception that the stock
price is everything that maybe a ten
dollar per share stock is truly cheaper
than a twenty dollar per share price
stock that is not the case when you
think about what you're paying for a
share of a company you have to think
about what the whole company is valued
at so let's say that there's a ten
dollar per share company but it has a
billion shares outstanding that means
ten dollars per share times a billion
shares that the companies valued at ten
billion dollars
on the other hand there might be another
company where the stock price is at a
hundred dollars per share but there's
only a million shares outstanding and so
that would be a hundred dollars times a
million or a hundred million dollar
company
now it doesn't necessarily mean that
let's say the 10 billion dollar company
is overpriced or that the 100 million
dollar company is underpriced what you
have to think about is why would you own
it well you would own it because
companies generate profits and in theory
those profits at some point are going to
come to the shareholders or someone else
might want to buy that company so for
example that 10 billion dollar company
might be making a billion of profit a
year while the 100 million dollar
company might be making only five
million dollars of profit a year now can
get more complex you might be willing to
pay more if the company is growing if
you think that there's going to be
something exciting that happens in the
future
now the last thing i will point out is
when you buy a stock
you are buying it from someone else so
it's tempting to look at the stock
market as this magical thing that just
moves up and down but it's just people
buying and selling shares in these
companies so if you think you have an
edge on someone you just have to think
about well why are they actually selling
it